gaskrise da gibt es ein ganz neues
problem nämlich die sorge dass wenn ganz
schnell energie gebraucht wird öl
gebraucht wird kohle gebraucht wird dass
das gar nicht dahin kommt wo man es
braucht weil der zugverkehr so langsam
ist weil die flüsse im moment nicht
befahren werden können ausgedruckt und
was macht man da dazu haben habeck der
wirtschaftsminister und der
verkehrsminister wissen gerade einen
absoluten notfall plan vorgestellt das
ist
erinnert hat eben eine verordnung
beschlossen für die ich sehr dankbar bin
eine verordnung die auf dem schienenwege
kohle und öl zu priorisieren kann wenn
notwendig zur energieversorgung
dass das notwendig werden kann dass
wegen eines niedrigen pegelstände der
deutschen flüsse vor allem eins rein ist
ja wir haben damit eine rechtsgrundlage
geschaffen um schnell handeln zu können
wenn der bedarf besteht energie
transporte zu priorisieren wir haben
eine knappheit situation auf der schiene
wir haben einen richtigen run auf die
schiene die schiene ist voll ausgelastet
und deswegen bedeutet das wenn
kurzfristig zusätzliche transporte im
energiebereich erforderlich sind dass
wir priorisieren müssen im zweifel kann
das auch bedeuten dass personenzüge
warten müssen das wird dann keine
einfache entscheidung
sprechen wir darüber mit unserer
kollegin nadja aswad und der letzte satz
hat uns noch einmal aufhorchen lassen
nadja das bedeutet auch dass
personenzüge auch mal warten müssen
jetzt ist es ja nicht so dass es bei der
bahn immer sowieso schon glatt läuft und
dass sich jeder schon sowieso gewohnt
ist dort am bahnsteig rumzustehen mit
welchen befürchtungen gehst du da jetzt
in die zukunft jetzt so wird auf den
schienen ja noch voller was bedeutet das
für viele pendler für viele menschen die
jetzt in den zügen sitzen wollen
genau das heißt in der tat dass wir uns
darauf einstellen müssen dass wir noch
länger warten müssen weil wir erleben
das ja jetzt genau wie du schon richtig
gesagt hast die deutsche bahn hat sehr
große probleme mit der bereitstellung
und den betrieb von zügen was ja
eigentlich ihre kernaufgabe sein sollte
und auch ist aber wir erleben ja schon
jetzt jeden tag dass das hinten und
vorne nicht klappt insofern bin ich da
sehr gespannt und gucke da auch mit
gemischten gefühlen in die zukunft weil
der bundesverkehrsminister hat ganz klar
gemacht dass kann so nein es muss aber
nicht sein man bereitet sich darauf vor
dass es sein muss ich finde gut dass man
schon mal einen plan ausgearbeitet hat
dass es zumindest sehr positiv aber wie
dass ich am ende denn darstellt wenn man
im ece sitzt und dann rauscht ein
kohletransport vorbei oder knattert viel
mehr vorbei weil ich glaube rauschen
wird da gar nichts na ja das werden dann
alle pendlerinnen und pendler erleben
wenn die in zügen warten müssen
tatsächlich das klingt irgendwie nicht
nach einem großen industrieland oder
also wenn es heißt jetzt ja da müssen
hier müsst ihr warten in euren
schnellzügen weil dann fährt erst mal
mit 50 stundenkilometern so ein güterzug
mit kohle oder mit öl vorbei und das
alles nachdem die bundesregierung mit
neun euro ticket eigentlich wollte dass
jetzt alle auf die bahn in den in den
personen öffentlichen personenverkehr
umsteigen also jetzt heißt es wieder
riesenprobleme da in den verkehr klingt
irgendwie nicht alles nach einem super
industriestandort
in der tat ist das tatsächlich nicht
also man muss sich tatsächlich freuen
dass es diesmal im plan gibt dass man
frühzeitig einen plan ausgearbeitet hat
und man kann nur hoffen dass die am ende
nicht gebraucht wird weil wir merken ja
es klappt jetzt schon hinten und vorne
nicht und auf der schiene rollt gar
nichts das steht und stockt er man kann
sich freuen wenn der zug da ist wenn er
pünktlich ist wenn er alle wagen hat und
wenn dann auch die klimaanlage oder die
heizung gehen also was muss passieren
muss das jetzt einfach wieder
hoffentlich viel regnen mehr wasser im
rhein so dass auch der schiffverkehr das
abnehmen kann also was muss passieren
damit wir eben nicht in die situation
kommen dass wir noch mehr warten müssen
wenn wir pendler sind und in die
arbeiten müssen und in zug nehmen wollen
genau das wäre tatsächlich sehr sehr gut
wenn die pegelstände wieder steigen
würden nun hat darauf niemanden einfluss
ist es gut dass es diesen plan gibt dass
der ausgearbeitet wurde und wir können
wahrscheinlich nur das beste hoffen dass
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
danach noch erklärt hat war ja dass die
energiesparmaßnahmen auch noch nicht
ausreichend also man hat ja auch
umfangreicher maßnahmen vorgestellt für
städte für bürogebäude wie man da
energie einsparen will hat gesagt das
spart vielleicht zwei zweieinhalb
prozent aber auch das wird noch nicht
reichen man kann sich nicht zurücklehnen
mann ist noch nicht entspannt ich glaube
das sind ehrlich gesagt ja keine so gute
nachrichten und ich bin gespannt wie das
am ende ausgeht und man kann nur das
beste hoffen habe ich fast den eindruck
[Musik]